so can you say any Assyrian words no I
don't know anything
about seconds did you ever think you
would make it I feel I'm so I tast Sweet
Victory know this life me for me yeah
why would you bet on Goliath when we got
bet David value taming giv values contes
this world of entrepreneurs we get no
value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the
one okay so folks we have a special uh
guest here today specifically because
after what happened yesterday with the
list that came out what's this list
called Vinnie it's called the
Jeffrey Epstein list we figured a lot of
people may need a lawyer we may as well
bring a qualified lawyer now whether she
accepts the offers or not obviously
that's not on us but today's guest I is
is none other than uh Alina Haba and by
the way before we get started I think we
got to give the breaking news
heartbreaking news Vinnie to to the
world everybody your especially this is
this small community of people that are
listening to this we get message left
and right did you know she's a Syrian
did you know she's she's a Syrian
cousin's brother yeah and and guess what
Elina it's great to have you on a
podcast but are you a Syrian the world
wants to know oh my God I'm sorry you
broke I am so proud of my middle eastern
background I am not a Syrian so tell us
about the background so my parents are
100% Iraqi born Baghdad Iraq and um you
know they're The American Dream came
over here and my father's a physician
but I am a Catholic Arab I am one of the
very few left in the world you know I am
Roman Catholic my parents are from
Baghdad and if you speak Arabic to me
I'll understand you but I'll answer you
in English because I'm very shy
literally you speak it I do understand
most of it yeah got it well very cool
now we know that but you know even if
you're from Iraq there's there could be
you got to cling on something right
there there could be somebody in the
lineage that could have been a Syrian
I'm all for it for it I represent I
represent whatever you need me to
represent I represent so we had we had
uh we we were one day we were at a uh uh
family comes over friends and family
comes over to the house it's me and Jen
sitting there this lady's like P you
ever done An ancestry uh you know.com
test before I'm like no but I know what
I am you know Armenian Assyrian Aramaic
all this stuff you just got to do the
test have you done one yet or not well
I'm afraid of
giving that's that's what one of us was
saying so let's test it out yeah so it
came out it said 18% Italian you yeah
100 I can 100% age call mom and my dad I
said guys who hooked up with mom got
offended dad didn't understand the
question dad just walks out of the room
I'm like I just want to know where's
Vinnie you know where is a Tony you I'm
just looking for a Johnny give me a name
you got the dark hair I mean I got the
dark hair the nose the
the and all the interviews of Mafia
people I mean kind of making sense today
is about you so it's great to have you
on because uh and the timing of it is
kind of weird obviously we going talk
about what's going on with uh uh the
president Trump what they're doing to
him we'll talk about a lot of other
things your background you know your uh
uh very in interesting character right
now as a lawyer you're out there you're
tough you're strong you're confident
you're imposing you're pushing back
you're not afraid you're Relentless you
still keep a smile on your face it's not
easy to do and I'm sure uh the job that
you have right now all eyes on you
requires you to be constantly reading
investigating researching at the same
time you don't want to give any kind of
inclination of you know that they're
pushing too hard and any of that stuff
because you want to show that you're you
know you got all this stuff under
control so right what everything going
on right now with the president okay I
mean we hear about Maine we hear about
Colorado right but if you can pull this
up with some other states that they're
even thinking about it right so the
orange uh States Colorado and Maine are
the ones that are officially
disqualified right decision appeal
disqualified great green challenge
dismiss or rejected don't even think
about it right the baby blue whatever
that color is they're not even part
participating the yellows Oregon Nevada
California I think uh uh Nome came out
and said we're not even going to be
participating in that so he kind of put
that out there for whatever reason
political reasons he put Arizona New
Mexico Texas Louisiana Florida Alaska
all these other states we know some of
them are not going to do anything with
it but those could still possibly make a
push to challenge to uh disqualify the
president for running is this purely a
show is this like they're just doing
this to make the the voters sit there
and say oh my God we shouldn't vote for
them or do they have any kind of a
chance of making it hard for the
president to win in 20124 do they have
no I mean look at the numbers so first
let's start with the legal part of that
right so legally if you say to me Alina
legally in the Constitution have you
ever seen a case where somebody who has
not been charged with Insurrection
somebody who has not gone to court and
been found guilty of insurrection should
be disqualified based on the 14th
Amendment
Insurrection if you say that to anybody
who's a lawyer or a non-lawyer the
answer is very simply no that's insane
that could never happen but it is
happening because we've seen my favorite
is me I like to talk about the main
woman she gets up and I I'm not making
light of it
but um section
32 she it says insurrectionist and he
said go PE peacefully and patriotically
so that's Insurrection and uh because of
that I'm going to take him off myself I
mean you want me to actually take her
seriously I look at I'm like honey no no
no she's not a lawyer right Elena no
she's not no and she I mean it was EP I
I laughed I hate to say it I laughed
that doesn't mean it's not serious that
doesn't mean we don't have to now deal
with it but when you look at even
Colorado there was dissenting opinion
that was Furious and said we're doing
the wrong thing but I think we have
these charged up radical left that see
the poll numbers go up and are so uh
ignorant the fact that they are a major
part of that this Behavior this woman is
a major part of why his poll numbers go
up it's not the only part our country
was amazing under him uh obviously and
we have a crazy
terribly decrepit economic situation
right now borders fentanyl Etc but um no
but what is that but
alen this 14th Amendment anytime you
turn on the news whether it's Fox
whether it's MSNBC whether it's CNN
anywhere you go 14th Amendment 14th
Amendment 4 section three section three
section three which essentially says
anyone that's running for office that
has taken the oath of the Constitution
whether it's president Congress person
Senator if they've been what uh engaged
in Insurrection or Rebellion against the
United States if they taken the oath of
office or supported the enemies thereof
is no longer qualified so pack this
situation because the 14th Amendment I
believe was written right after the
Civil War citizenship to anyone born or
naturalized you just makes sense of the
actual Amendment and then this the
section yeah I mean look I I I can never
pretend to be an Alan dersu or Mark lvin
they're so epically intelligent when it
comes to the Constitution and I think
I've earned my stripes but I will say in
very simple terms this was not meant for
this this was done um so that you didn't
have people who are anti-American be
able to take a position of office
especially after War it is in an extreme
scenario it was built for the
Confederacy for the Confederacy exactly
anti-American mentality everything to
make sure that we don't go back to
slavery to make sure that we don't go
back to things that we don't want this
country to go back to having someone
question election Integrity having a
president not someone a sitting
president who makes up the entire
executive branch say I'm concerned about
election integrity and I see things
happen at 400 a.m. that don't make sense
to me I see a scale if you look there
was a chart right and it shows you know
here we go and and then all of a sudden
2 o' boom Biden's up I mean it was very
strange and you can't say that there is
perfect ballots and election Integrity
in this country nobody can say that so
to bring in these cases and try and go
under the 14th Amendment and I've had
case after case where they use this
Leticia James is another we can get to
later they use statutes they use
amendments that are not meant for this
because of desperation so I'm not
concerned I think that the Supreme Court
is going to have to address this I think
that once they make that decision it
will put this all to an end and Elena if
if you're the average American sitting
back I don't care what side you you're
what party you're on what side you claim
and you're watching this all play out
it's obvious what they're doing how do
you how do you trust the justice system
when it's it's in your face that the guy
that's in first place you're trying to
chop off his leg I don't like how do you
even I don't like the average American
with your case and your problem if they
could do that to to him literally
actively cheating and trying to get them
wrong how do you how do you go to court
and like I have to go to court tomorrow
and trust these people anybody you know
I've heard that people and and this is a
problem that we're seeing now people are
worried about how to register to vote
they don't want to register to vote as a
Party voter because they're afraid that
if they're identified as a Republican or
a Democrat that they'll be treated a
different way when they go to court
because those are public filings right
so so that's something that's been a
repercussion they say oh my goodness I
can't be affiliated with the Republican
party so I'm going to close the the
curtain vote red but I'll say that I'm
independent or I just won't register to
any party it's crazy that is so an
American Y and then in regards to CU I I
heard you say to an interviews all the
attorney generals District Attorneys are
all Soros they are honestly right and I
know you guys by the way he looks if you
haven't seen Googled uh George Soros
that's the epitome of evil face look
well he's antih humanitarian honestly
that's exactly Elon mus said that he
he's he's he wants to erod the very
fabric of civilization and that he hates
Humanity what do you what do you think
alinaa is the goal of like somebody like
him a powerful Elite that just wants to
destroy the country that they live in I
I don't I've been trying bizarre it's I
think that what they're looking for and
what we're seeing in Washington right
now and look I'm I'm a lawyer I happen
to be uh in the political realm as an
attorney but I'm not a politician but I
will say that I deal with the doj I deal
with the FBI I deal with these entities
and the Das and the AGS and I see what
they do behind closed doors I see how
they manipulate things and I will say
that there is no question that they are
so
self-interested that their thoughts are
not about the benefit of our children
their thoughts are not about the benefit
of our economy it's about Nancy Pelosi
making $100 million off stock somehow
when she's on $180,000 salary this is
what we're in and it's almost like a
Fame epidemic I think I think that some
of these AGS and Das and the fannies and
the Latias and if you look at them they
love having pressers they love having
press conferences Jack Smith they love
having press conferences getting in
front having their moment it's almost a
narcissistic and then I got to go out
there and fight the BS that they just
spewed I mean I'll never forget the
first time I had to do it off the cuff
and it's all because this guy paid money
to their campaign and now they have some
promises to fulfill and that's the
opposite of Donald Trump which is why
I'm so proud to represent him he's not
bought he's not bought should that be
allowed should that be allowed where
because this this could work you know
like we had uh Paul man for here and
we're talking about lobbyist lobbyist
are ruining America etc etc hey you know
we shouldn't let people run for office
and raise billions of dollars with these
super packs and all this other stuff and
look at the kind of money that this
person's raising that person's raising
well let's just say we eliminate the
attack let's just say we eliminate Loban
let's just say we
eliminate a guy like Soros funding your
lawsuit does that make everything Level
Playing Field or should people like
Soros be allowed to fund other people's
lawsuit because if somebody like the
midest touch right whatever or the left
or CNN or these guys right so they may
sit there and say freaking awesome what
Soros is doing to them he may be a hero
to many of them may be like what a great
guy he is he cares about democracy right
they they may sell something like that
to the average viewer but should that
even be allowed on both sides
specifically funding other people's
lawsuits no no so what would happen if
we so so do you mind walking us through
it so let's just say that doesn't happen
yeah who loses who wins so unfortunately
here's an issue that'll come from not
having Financial backing through packs
right packs obviously are important
because running for office running for
presidency costs a lot of money and you
do want to level the playing field to
some regard to make sure that everybody
can compete fairly right you don't want
to have Trump's a billionaire and uh
let's you know Chris Christie is you
know has 100 Grand so we he is not going
to be able to compete right I want Chris
Christie to be able to try and compete
with Trump and I want them to say look
you all have funding VC lot of funding
the numbers are just not where Trump is
so at the end of the day I don't think
it necessarily hurts us what hurts us is
this legal backing the AGS and da that's
where I say you have no business putting
money into the legal system and meaning
judicial the FBI the doj backing them
Leticia James you know they're all
politicians and they get backed and then
they have to keep promises so I don't
like that now something for president
something that major I don't see how
they could do it without it um but in
terms of these individual states having
political backing that concerns me
because you're seeing targeting and I'm
I'm there in court and the targeting you
hear about in the media is nowhere near
as bad as it actually is I can assure
you she campaigned on basically
Prosecuting Trump that was her that was
her campaign message but back to Pat's
question you know you hear uh campaign
Finance reform the citizens united yeah
ruling under Justice Roberts in what
early 2000 2008 I want to say whatever
it was how much of a fact is that in all
this for me not um I I stay out of the
campaign I intentionally am not hired by
the campaign so I you know you can
choose to stay out of it I think that's
a good example right I am not a campaign
person I don't want to be on the
campaign right now that's not where my
best use of time is if I were on the
campaign and I was backed by one of
these campaign finances or some donor
for president Trump right and I was
getting paid that way um people would I
think discredit some of what I say and I
think that's just a choice are we going
to stop it the reality is no we're not
they try and reform it reformed I mean I
I think they're trying to be as as
expose you know they're trying to expose
as much as they can and you can do your
research and do it and look at who's
giving to who and what but I don't know
I don't know that it will ever happen to
be honest I mean the country is a
political country in a way that's what
makes us a democracy right because we do
have politics and it's gotten completely
out of control and isn't the entire
premise of that you'll you'll way more
of an expert than than us on this oh I'm
not a campaign expert no but you
understand law and I this your lawyer
representing Donald Trump isn't it the
fact that corporations are people yeah
isn't that what essentially the the
argument is with that citizens united
yeah they are people they are people and
they have voices and they also have a
lot of money but you know I think it's
up to the candidates can I be honest
with you you can get F somebody could
fund me and say here I'm giving you a
billion dollars to run for president and
I'm to fund you but if I'm not going to
be one of those puppets like that's just
not who I am I never would be uh
president Trump never would be he
wouldn't come and be like I promise to
make you it's just not who he is I know
that because he he treats us all that
way you know I I had to earn my stripes
with him you have to earn respect and
nothing you do uh you know will give him
that no checkw writing will do that for
him so I will say um there are others
like Pelosi and Schumer that make me
concerned whether it's corporate whether
it's uh you know some entity that's
looking for for wokeness and to trans to
transition your children at 2 years old
you know I I can't have that I mean but
they'll do some of them will sign their
life away for anything so so it's
interesting you said that about Pelosi I
think we need to give her proper respect
Rob if you can pull up uh uh some of the
you know the the greatest stock Pickers
of 2023 she will be upset cuz she
dropped she drops off she dropped she's
going to be upset with this report go
ahead can you pull it all the way down
to the numbers drop keep going keep
going keep going here's who led the way
in 2023 in stocks held and the returns
in 2023 look all the way at the top can
you zoom in a little bit Brian we got to
properly recognize these guys Brian
Higgins
238% rate of return in 2023 Democrat
Mark green 122 Republican Garrett Graves
David Rouser All Above 100% Seth Molton
uh Ron wien Joel Rutherford uh Richard
Blumenthal 68 Pelosi 6 she dropped off I
mean she that's very disappointing God
she's not number nine she she's in the
top 10 but I'm sure must not have been
there for her this year knowing knowing
how competitive she is she's probably
very frustrated with this list but going
back dude you said you know the whole
idea about you know uh you got to earn
your stripes working with him okay
you're young and president Trump's been
around the block God knows how many
lawyers he's hired over the years you
know we've had friends that have worked
with them high standards High
expectation driving everybody around him
he's a guy that sells he's a guy that
drives he's a guy that pushes challenges
all of that right how do you earn your
stripes with a guy like uh president
Trump I would say there's two things um
number one you have to work hard I
there's not an easy day since I've
started working with the president um he
he doesn't like lazy uh there's
obviously tremendous amount of I hate to
use this word but grifters there's a lot
of grifters around and we see them we
feel them it's um tough to be around but
he sees through that and sometimes we
don't catch them you know they come out
and bite us but you have to work hard
you can't be there for the ride for free
to just come on and use his name and you
can't avoid them all the time but I
think he knows with me look I I was a
member at his club before I worked for
him I always say that I I like people
know that because I like to say that I
earned my stripes prior to president
Trump I was independently uh successful
and always worked hard I graduated
college in three years I started a firm
when I was in my 20s I that's who I am
um and those people are very different
than the people who are not known um get
to know him and then hop on the
bandwagon you know that's just different
and they can earn their stripes and
he'll respect that but you got to work
hard you got to work hard it doesn't
hurt that I win cases that
helps you know winning always helps he
doesn't uh want anybody on his team
representing him that's you know going
to keep failing of course um so that
helped I won my first case with him very
quickly and it kind of went from there
and then um outside of that I think
loyalty it's something he talks about
all the time but loyalty in not a
cryptic Mafia way I hate using that word
because people then say look at this
person now they're in jail because they
were too loyal like no just loyalty
meaning you're not here to use him and
then go somewhere else you're here
because you want to be because you
believe in it and you're loyal to that
cause and the cause for me is America is
my children so that's my loyalty and he
knows that my my goal is not uh anything
but that so how much do you think well
let me phrase it this way you're capable
you're smart you're intelligent you're
loyal you have all the qualifications
but you're also an attractive woman yeah
you know we saw what happened with
Johnny Depp when you know Amber on the
on the stand and Johnny depps lawyer
female capable amazing there's just a
different Dynamic when a woman is
questioning a woman or a woman is
basically representing a man you know
say what you will about Trump Alpha man
you know you you you would suspect he
picks an alpha guy but he picks a
feminine smart capable woman how much of
you being an attractive smart woman do
you think played a role in this to him
or in the public cuz I can tell you it's
been a double-edged sword it's been
something I have had to deal with in the
positive and in the negative I don't
think I would be on TV or sitting here
if I didn't look the way I look I think
I caught attention I'm I'm very honest
about that and I don't mind I'm an I'm
not a feminist okay I believe in strong
women but I want my door opened I I am
very much an old school my parents are
Middle Eastern old school woman I I when
I'm at home I cook I I have a husband I
respect I know how to turn it off but do
I not think that if um you know I I'll
tell you something somebody said to me
Alina would you rather be um would you
rather be smart or
pretty and I said oh easy pretty I can
fake being
smart but I meet him all the time
alinaa you know I mean that's the honest
truth and it's going to make me you know
I'm sure there'll be some Washington
Post article about it tomorrow Daily
Beast my favorite but listen like you
have to be honest it doesn't hurt to be
goodlook in this world in the pr World
on TV it doesn't hurt and when you're
goodlook that's great but it can also
mean people think you're stupid or
people think that President Trump hired
me because I was good-look that is
absolutely not the case and um I've won
cases many cases for him I've won many
cases before him I represent other other
people I've owned my own Law Firm I'm
independently like I said I'm a hard
worker and I think that it's a
combination of both and if anybody wants
to pretend otherwise then you're just
being Sil when you said double-edged
sword obviously anyone that represents
Trump trump himself the media is just
going to try to eviscerate do you think
that the media has maybe treated you a
little bit more fairly because you're a
woman you know believe all women
everything that's going on in the media
the feminist movement you think they've
been harder on you or when I first
started they were awful I remember the
first hit piece I got uh there was The
Daily Beast um did an article on me Jose
paleri
and it was probably two days in or two
months into to me actually working for
him and it said the one Trump lawyer
everybody hates and they talked about
how they thought I was hired cuz I was
pretty how the rest of the attorneys at
uh Trump organ on the Trump team didn't
like me all probably true by the way he
he definitely had sources there were
quotes um and at that moment I have to
tell you it was the hardest I I remember
laying on the floor I'm a human being I
laid on the floor in my office in
Bedminster I shut the door and I cried
and I was like oh I can't do this I
can't do this really and I'm a tough
cookie but um I remember what I did was
I was in court on the Attorney General
case when it was still a special
proceeding it was it's been going on for
three years and I saw Jose paleri in the
back row and he can attest to this I
walked right up to him and I said you
wrote the nastiest nastiest hit piece on
me damn and goes he was shocked and I
said I don't appreciate it and my family
doesn't appreciate it and I said when
you actually want to get to know me you
let me know wow and since then yeah
there it is there's the first there
what's the date on that I can't even see
November 2nd 20 what was it 22 2020 no
but it was published March 21st 22 March
21st so I had been working with him for
almost for a few months almost six
months and um I got ridic yeah her name
is out almost out of nowhere relatively
unknown that's so not true I had cases
that were in the news prior um that were
big cases and you know it's just crazy
but he to this day is somebody now I
speak to Jose he'll still write some hi
pieces but he got to know me and he
won't write him like that that's great
you held him accountable respect good
for you la last question on this topic
cuz this fascinates me how you can be
attractive and feminine and capable but
also
being this a personal question so does
our audience for how you I I asked yeah
hook me up I asked the same question to
Candace Owens as but you know the two
don't don't have to be mutually
exclusive you could be an attractive and
you can be a businesswoman how do you
balance that I think like I said you
have to have boundaries there has to be
a place where you're feminine and you're
and by the way I'm still feminine I wore
a pink suit to court in the Attorney
General case and did a press conference
and was on one of ones that was most um
put on and look part of my brand if I
even have a brand yet but brand is that
I like to dress well I like nice things
I don't feel like I have to wear a plain
blue suit and a turtleneck and put my
hair in a ponytail it's not who I am I
used to work in fashion I love that part
of me so why do I have to you know I get
I put a post up for instance it's a good
example I put a post up I was at a UFC
fight and and um I was wearing neck had
a nice
necklace I did not see that one coming
so I I I go up there and I'm wearing a
dress I'm 39 years old I'm not wearing a
dress down to my ankles I'm not wearing
a turtleneck I'm going to dress my age
and they how dare you dress like that
you're Trump's lawyer and I just want to
say to all those people I'm a human
being I have a husband I have a life and
I'm 39 I'm going to be who I am now I am
obviously respectful I'm not going to
come out looking like you know you don't
want to encourage bad comments but I am
who I am and I own it and at the end of
the day I think the most important
person is when you're with your family
at home and and who that person is and
that is a much more feminine person
unfortunately on the phone too much but
much more feminine person who cooks who
wants to have a husband take care of her
and not be in charge um and and I know
my place by the way when I'm with a team
of older lawyers who have a hard time
with young females and that happens and
I know that there's sometimes I have to
be more submissive but I know when the
time is you know and that's that's the
key in front of the TV no forget it I
I'm barking March
25th 40th birthday coming up you excited
about it I I always thought I'd be
depressed about it and now I'm like I've
done more in 40 years than some people
have done in their lifetime so I'm
really happy I'm proud I'm excited to
see you ought to be you're doing great
thank you so so let's let's stay on this
topic with uh specifically we started
off with this topic we went all over the
place I feel like we got to know you a
little bit but let's go back to the
topic so okay Colorado out Maine out
they got a few more left that's going to
happen how how ugly could this get the
reason why I asked this question this I
don't know if you guys have followed
this story or not this year is the
biggest election year in the history of
the world election year 40 elections
happen at the same time the largest
Christian Nation the two largest Muslim
nations all at the same time 40 plus
countries 3.2 billion people will be
voting this year will be able outow to
vote this year 44 billion $44 trillion
dollar of GDP all this year right so
we're talking Pakistan election this
year India election this year us
election this year a Belgium I can go on
there's 40 countries elections this year
right when there is so many you know
things going on the people who have had
control behind closed doors that we
don't know what do they fear they fear
losing control
okay and and the number one piece
amongst all these 40 elections going on
around the world 3.2 billion people
potentially voting the number one Domino
not the second Domino the number one
Domino is a guy named Donald Trump okay
so if he gets elected the people who
control can't control him correct cuz a
lot of these other guys can be
controlled so for a voter that's sitting
that looked at Vox came out and said 55%
chance Trump's going to be the president
Vox is not a conservative side they're
liberal they're predicting same 55%
chance Trump's going to end up being
president this year so walk us through I
call 2023 the year of Investigations I
call this a year and a half ago it was
all investigations 2023 I'm calling this
to a year of chaos I think it's going to
be chaotic it's going to be crazy yeah
how crazy how chaotic could it get or do
you think no it's going to be pretty you
you know temper tantrums oh you know
Nevada's coming out and they coming out
they're just yapping and screaming and
hollering or could it actually get very
very ugly for the American people to
brace for
impact I mean I I wish I could give um
this is what I always say look I know a
lot more facts than I can share and the
facts are good so meaning the witch
hunts let's start there right so the
number one way that we've seen them try
and take him down the chess piece is
through uh legal legal cases and that is
what I know and without getting into
facts that I know that'll come out um
it's no different than any other case
when you know the facts as an attorney
and you know what actually happened
behind closed doors and you know what he
did and didn't do not what the Press is
saying he did not what the Jack Smiths
are saying he did or want you to believe
he did the real facts the fear level
comes down a lot then it becomes very
simple we have to be able to fight a
corrupt organization that's what it is
it's corrupt um and and that's where my
fear only lies in that you know I'm in
front of judges that we can give them
the facts and they are clean look at my
last trial I just ended but if you have
a judge who wants to get Trump wants to
take him down wants to be a part of
taking the chess piece down if you have
this main woman I don't even know her
name that's how how little I care what's
her name whatever you have this woman
wanting to be a lawyer wanting to be a
part of this liberal radical
movement and we don't have the ultimate
Court the Supreme Court check these
people that's when we're in trouble but
I do still have faith in the Supreme
Court so I think that right now for
Donald Trump for taking that piece off
it all goes frankly up to the Supreme
supreme court because everything we're
talking about is election interference
thank God yeah listen there isman oh
what a genius no no no what I'm go ahead
please finish I want to finish your
thoughts and I'll have a followup for
you yeah but I think that we have to
remember that everything we're worried
about with Trump is legal there's a
reason his lawyer is his
spokeswoman it's because it's all being
used in courts and through laws
Constitution it all goes up to the
Supreme Court and I really believe there
is a checks and balances still that
still exists in this country um the
executive branch you know is one person
but we all know that there's a hundred
other people behind it right now but the
Supreme Court stands independently and
that's on purpose and that's way our
founding founding fathers created it so
I believe that they will handle it I
believe that look what Jack Smith just
got shut down he was trying to rush they
said nope so as long as they stay firm I
have no fear because I will not win
every case let me be very clear you
cannot you cannot you have people that
are not listening to what you're saying
I'll get in court and I will say there
were no victims Deutsche Bank made money
Leticia James is using a completely
inappropriate statute here's the facts
and here's a Nobel executive uh expert
who's going to tell you that this is
complete BS and the judge will go no
that's fine I'm going to lose that's
fine but I need the Supreme
Court to to be the one that has the
reason the the one that holds America
together right now that's where I think
this country needs to be strong so so um
okay by the way just think about it he
so Trump's first president that flips
three seats right say he doesn't that's
what I was just going to ask if he
doesn't flip those three seats you're
assed out yeah literally right I mean if
screwed yeah you're screwed there's
nothing by the way nothing he can so
paint a picture say the Supreme Court is
you know 63 the other way around
whatever 54 63 the other way around okay
and you don't have have any protection
there how ugly could it have gotten for
PR the president if Supreme Court was
the other way fli 63 look if if they
have it their way they would have him in
jail that's what I'm saying if you need
me to say it I'll say it it's absolutely
true they would have him in jail because
they can't the movement the American
movement it's not a mega movement it's
an American movement it's people afraid
of losing our country and it's a
movement because we're I'm scared I'm
scared of what I've seen you know and
that is uh the problem and that's why
they get behind Trump so if you can't
beat him if you're worried that stealing
an
election may get screwed up what else do
you do you put your opponent in jail and
that's you you tell me that Jack Smith
Fanny da Alvin Bragg uh Leticia James
you tell me that those people wouldn't
have a private party if Donald Trump was
in jail of course that's sick overnight
that's sick right but but but but go
there go so now flip it so strategy
let's talk about strategy is they're not
dumb right so they know they don't have
Supreme Court they they know it they
they don't have it right right so you're
pushing Maine Colorado do are they
celebrating saying oh look what we did
oh we impeached the president so he's
the most impeach president of all time
hey look at Colorado Maine try to remove
off the ballot but you failed do are
they thinking that that's helping them
are they that dumb to think that going
about trying to get them off Main in
Colorado but failing is a victory like
they're not dumb these are not dumb
manipulators so how do they see that as
a victory knowing Supreme Court doesn't
have their back well that's the thing I
don't think that they're all working in
tandem all the time I think the
individual from Maine was not being very
bright to be honest I think that that
was a silly move and it's going to with
people Colorado I mean the minute they
said ear was off the ballot the reaction
is oh we could win Colorado like you
know that's they're not understanding I
don't know you're right they're not dumb
but I think their point is to disrupt
and concern and make everyone scared
that this person's a predator he's a
fraudster with banks he's a this he's a
that Insurrection insurrectionist you
know I have a trial coming up same thing
they're going to do the woman card again
and it's like they just don't stop now
again another funded lawsuit Reed
Hoffman funding that lawsuit um LinkedIn
LinkedIn he funded the first one and
then I think he dropped out or whatever
but this is all legal Warfare at the end
of the day they aren't that bright
because people want to make a name for
themselves and I think they thought they
were go I'll be honest with you I think
they thought we're all going to do it
we're going to attack and we're going to
make it happen before the 2024 election
these cases are years and years old
they're from when he was president
president some of them and Georgia for
instance you waited years Leticia James
three years I've been on that case that
case was in a special proceeding for
three years the minute they filed the
complaint they wanted the case in six
months so they wanted to destroy
credibility in his business which is
where everybody has confidence in
president Trump because the country was
run like a business they want to destroy
him with
women my Bergdorf Goodman case coming up
he'll get you know money damages another
judge that's anti-trump we we'll see the
whole thing and then we they want to
destroy him criminally make you believe
he's a criminal and anti-American
insurrectionist anti-American they want
to hit him on all fronts and by the way
we don't even know what the October
surprise is going to be I feel like I've
been in an October surprise for a year
but they're trying to hit you so that
you lose faith in him but what they're
forgetting is you're so obvious that we
have more faith in him because he hasn't
quit I would have quit I mean he has not
quit he has not come down he has not
stopped talking he has not become more
reserved he is who he is and uh and I'm
not worried in that regard but I'm
telling you they would try and put him
in jail Rob can you pull up that article
uh the article the first article we
covered two days ago uh that America
wants a strong tough you know uh you
know which one I'm talking about if you
just typed down it'll come up so story
came out uh Left Right Center doesn't
matter only reason I'm showing this to
you is because some of the people that
are going to watch this podcast um okay
go lower go lower and and so look at
this chart here across the political
Spectrum Americans seek tough leaders
who will crack down okay so you'll see
the dark green strongly agree agree
disagree strongly disagree and then
you'll see on the left the categories
they have a strong Democrat not strong
lean Democrat independent lean rep
Republican ET all the way to the bottom
obviously on all the way to the bottom
what do you notice 90% agree that
America seeks a tough leader that will
crack down okay all the way at the
bottom a strong Democrat though is still
59% yeah they strongly agree or agree
okay only 42% disagree and strongly
disagree by the way that is catastrophic
nothing about this category represents
Joe Biden because if you go all the way
to the top of the article gold way to
the top of the article so it says what
are the key words strong Biden is not
strong rough Biden is not rough except
when he's going down the stairs anti
anti-democratic leader okay they would
call Biden a democratical leader let's
just say and the way they wrote this
article obviously it's a little bit of a
word smithing and kind of manipulation
that's going with it but do you think
America's kind of sitting there saying
what are you guys doing yeah you think
even some of the people on the left are
sitting there saying what do you think
you're doing to this guy like we don't
even like the guy but you're making us
like the guy you're making us like
you're making us like the guy that we
didn't like you know four or five years
ago you think
people say that to me all the time like
we we were on the fence or we were left
and now we're not and you see that a lot
with especially minorities or people
that feel like they're unfairly
prosecuted and come into this country
from other countries where they've seen
the Banana Republic a lot of those
people like my family get more behind
Trump because we know where this is
going we know where this is going now
it's not a joke you know tick destroying
our children's mentality and lack of
strong home base lack of faith is
destroying our culture and once you dis
you dismantle all of that we're easily
manipulated and we believe that a man
that can't walk and eats ice cream is
not being backed by Obama who's still in
Washington I mean I'm not a conspiracy
person I'm not but I'm not a stupid
person and I know that man can't run the
country and I know when Epstein's list
comes out
and one name's blacked out and Bill
Clinton's been doing you know was we saw
it yesterday he likes them young he
likes them young what why are they not
in jail you're a pedophile that's called
a pedophile y so this is where our
country is headed and I do think that
people that come from um other countries
that are were not necessarily wealthy or
came from third world countries and come
to this country the right way by the way
when they come to this country the right
way they appreciate what we have and
they're afraid of losing it and they're
holding on to it strong and they realize
Donald Trump's the only way we're going
to keep it you said the uh real quick
because on this thing you said a key
word right there and I don't want to
skip it you said manipulated because I
feel like a lot of people in America
feel like they've been manipulated let
me unpack that you know they say like
fool me once yeah you know shame on you
fool me twice shame on me if like
there's a lot of people in America
especially swing v a president than the
pass said it in a different way and I
thought it was more entertaining
sh I Can't Get Fooled Again can't get it
you know what I'm
saying war criminal but go ahead shout
out to for that one but I feel like a
lot of people in America feel like
they've been fooled and they're not
going to let it happen again what do I
mean we all know what the media has done
and a lot of this is basically sort of
been exasperated since Co whether it's
co whether it's the jab whether it's you
know trust the science whether it's
fouchy whether it's what's going on on
the woke left what we're seeing going on
with Hamas and the Hamas Brigade going
on out there whether it's the trans
stuff all this with the feminist stff
everything like this just a lot of just
normal Americans people that have voted
voted for George W bush that have voted
for Biden that have voted I'm sorry for
for Obama that have voted for Trump they
flip they flip they flip they flip
Americans are bipolar the every 48 years
they vote for somebody else there's a
lot of them totally fine yeah it's the
American way I mean I'm talking about
the people in Michigan talking about the
people in Pennsylvania the people in
Wisconsin swing States Battleground
States feel there's a lot of people
basically saying you guys got me the
first time on Trump all the Mexicans are
raping okay you know all the stuff that
they put out there all good people on
both sides all the media I feel like
they're hipped to the game now and I
feel like they're looking at the
situation right now and they're like not
a fan of trump necessarily the
personality what have you but what I'm
seeing over here on the left I just
can't condone and I mean I'm one of
those people are like yeah but I feel
like at this point we do see that we're
we're losing our values we're for Joe
Biden just years ago in a dress
nonetheless not dress nonetheless I
never campaign anybody zero I don't love
any politic by the way I don't like
politics I don't I don't bow to any
politic what but but but it's she has to
the truth but but you may be the most
important person at the table always
because we we did a $1,000 beted on who
was going to win the election last time
and he voted and he won yeah in 2020
just so you know wow so yeah that's so
so for him to go from there to where
he's at now that's exactly what I'm
talking the point of America clear I
just I I followed the money the odds
were Joe Biden was the favorite whoever
the favorite is in Vegas I'm gonna take
okay so if you're gonna hang on you're
going to say something like that now
you're going to be held accountable hang
on fine so did you no no wait a wait a
minute you followed the money because of
Vegas odds great but did you also vote
the same way with Vegas odds yeah yes so
you also voted that's not following the
money you can follow the money and vote
the other way if it's just about the
money you also didn't want to vote for
Trump thank you Pat for bringing it up
to a th000 I really appreciate because
publicly I gave you a,s okay I gave you
a th000 bucks on a 10,000 bucks that bet
follow the money thank you I'm sure the
audience have no idea if you follow the
money now Hunter Biden's money goes
right into bid I would like to F FYI the
whole point is yes millions of people
believe it or not feel like he does I
agree I'm telling you millions of people
feel like he does and it's because of
what they're doing it's because of what
they're doing yeah but that's my point
that's the point that I'm making is
there's a lot of people who are like
yeah I don't know I I don't like either
them I mean look let's be clear nobody
wants to see a trump Biden rematch I'm
just letting you know but based on this
rematch there's a lot of people being
like I'll take Trump that's it they'll
hold their nose you heard I don't trust
them that it'll be B everyone says that
and everyone's going to keep saying that
and then in November you're going to
have a choice of Biden Trump yeah well
and L and we're still being in this uh
when you he look at the odds there Trump
is now Biden's two remember how Gavin's
moving
up by the way Biden was number one until
literally today yeah Michelle F Michelle
Michelle is still in the mix so soena in
regards to we keep hearing election
interference when you hear that I oh I
love doing this it's called cheating it
is thank you I'm tired of hearing
election interference and by the way the
left has been doing it and say what you
want they always blame they always blame
our side Russian collusion they tried
with the DNC with Hillary don't even get
me started don't even get all the
impeachment all that BS crap okay if
this tactic that they're doing right now
with everything that you're involved
with uh fails and he's allowed to be on
the ballot the left plays to win be
they'll stop at nothing what other
tactic or tactics do you think they
would use because we're see we saw the
movie Leave the World Behind it's almost
like they're letting us know Cyber
attack might happen they've warned us
about pandemic number two China the
China virus number two yeah China virus
number two what what's the other Scare
Tactics open border so if a terrorist
attack if it comes they're going to vote
by the way those 100 1,000% all those
migrants are voting 1,00% soena if it
comes down to it where they're like oh
crap none of the stuff with the the law
is working and we're getting close do
you think that they are willing to pull
the trigger on something else to disrupt
the election people have told me you
should be worried that they're going to
actually try and kill him I was just
going to ask you that too how how scared
is he how worried is he because he's
he's not because his he has his own
security correct but it's not about
security it's about you don't think
people have been trying that for I mean
now since
2015 he is not a fearful man right he's
not at the end of the day it's not about
how much security has look if somebody
wants to hurt somebody they will um I've
had people try and kill me I mean I'm
his lawyer oh yeah you you know crazy
people writing letter I'm going to kill
you when I get out of jail I'm going to
come after you and this guy raped and
killed a 5-year-old he's in some
Tennessee jail you know I've had to file
a criminal it's crazy the world we're in
right now but that's my point like
desperation makes you crazy so so I
don't think they'll stop at anything um
I think that at the end of the day they
will like I said try and put them in
jail they'll try anything they can but
more importantly it's our election
Integrity that concerns me because let's
say he's still on the ballot let's say
he's in jail let's say all those things
happen we have to go vote so what's the
last step what's the last step then mail
and
ballots migrants voting no voter ID and
the states have to handle that he can't
handle the states have to handle that
and I really wish they would start
really getting a grip on it I always say
why can't we have clear ID for voting
like I go to the the airport I have
clear ID I go in there they scan my eyes
I got one ticket I vote that's it no one
screwing with it the machines aren't
shut that machine racist don't I was
just kind make you feel like yeah you're
talking about ID I you've been keeping
up with the news it's racist because
apparently the left thinks black people
in Georgia don't know how to get idas so
that's racist to think that they they
they they would know how guess what then
do you are you actually prepared to vote
for the person who's running your
country making economic decisions
keeping us out of War things like that
like look there has to be a level
there's a reason we don't allow children
to vote you know you have to be smart
and at the end of the day not everyone's
always going to be included it's America
we're not you know we have rules we have
laws we have regulations we can't act
like those regulations make you a racist
make you um you know you you're not
saying the correct pronoun therefore you
hate Humanity like what the hell is
happening Alena this ID situation we
don't need to spend a lot of time on it
but it boggles my mind yeah I got to
show my ID if I'm going to buy liquor I
got to show my ID if I'm going to go to
a club I got anything you need ID sorry
voting like the number one thing that
you could do as a citizen is vote yeah I
think that's why is it such a sticking
point where it's a racist to have an ID
you can't expect people to have ID I
don't understand the ID can't
cheat exactly you can't cheat oh my God
we can't cheat it's very simple why why
can't we get ID to vote for the
president of this country well we can
but they don't want us to yeah that's
why the border is has been for the past
four years as we speak right now alinaa
right now the Border completely open 8
million people in and guess what those
people when they come in you know what
they tell them Joe Biden this Democrat
go in they probably give them a voting
thing when they pass go and go like
you're going to check blue yeah okay
they give this is why you're here here's
your cell phone here's a hotel room in
New York and here's your voting here's
your ballot I want you to take this and
maybe three more copies put it in the
mail and you're going to help us steal
the election I agree I think that's what
could be happening I do can I go back to
what Pat was discussing with the Supreme
Court because this is really what it
comes down to right I'm going to try
this by the way yeah go
it'll Jack you and it's cucumber so
you're in Middle Eastern you're going to
love it so the Supreme Court right the
Supreme Court um we've seen what's
happened in Colorado that was a month or
so ago Maine is a week ago whatever it
is you know Rob pulled up the uh the
image of there's a dozen other states
that are considering moving Trump in the
ballot I think 17 to be exact right so
walk us through what it means to be the
Supreme Court because they're not going
to hear all these
Court exactly they so they're going to
set a national president law of the land
here's what I learned about the Supreme
Court from pbd and kudos to pbd 2020 Pat
starts the podcast we're doing it
they're talking about you guys don't
understand how big of a deal it is that
they flipped these Supreme Court
Justices and then we started hearing
things like well Democrats Joe bidens
are going to pack the court they're
going to pack the court right there's
nine justices is that what it is well
they're going to go up to 11 they're
going up to 13 people are like how the
hell you even pack the I'm like what the
hell is this even all about the Supreme
Court packing the court we're learning
things we're like what is this going
down here but at the end of the day it's
a 63 right so you know on there's a
liberal side of things you've got Sodom
myor and you've got Kagan and then you
have sort of the the the right you got
the uh Clarence Thomases of the world
and you got the alos of the world but
then you have sort of let's just say
more moderate whether it's um uh Comey
Barrett or whether it's gorik or whether
it's the Supreme Court Justice Roberts
whatever but at the end of the day Trump
appointed the people who are the
moderates the gorix the Amy Comber so if
this does go to the Supreme Court yeah
walk us through how this works the
vision of because 6 listen this is
what's going to happen it's not really
about the other states right you asked
me about these other states could do it
it's not going to matter at this point
because we just yes I think it was
yesterday or two days ago uh filed with
the Supreme Court for Colorado um Maine
obviously on appeal but one decision
needs to be made because they're all
trying and Maine tried to do it under
some small section I guess or whatever
it is but we just have to have
acknowledgement as to what the rules and
regulations are here to me it's not
something I'm worried about because it's
so obvious it's so clearcut there's due
process there's an Antiquated and
completely misplaced 14th amendment
being used there's there's just Basics
here that haven't happened that a
decision that he could be off the ballot
at this point at this point right to me
would be mindblowing so I'll be honest
with you you you obviously have concerns
about all the other states and I don't I
think the Supreme Court is going to see
it I'm not worried about if you're uh
moderate or if you're left because I
think this is one of those really
clearcut constitutional issues that um
should just be hands down and how can
you remove someone from B like Supreme
Court yeah he hasn't been found guilty
of everything you can think that it was
an Insurrection all you want yeah it was
a headline for them and I think but he
hasn't he hasn't been found guilty of
anything he hasn't even been
charged me never mind guilty you're not
even charged that's that's my point here
so like you're talking about du process
he hasn't been charged he hasn't been
found guilty none of it but how do they
remove some from ballot you're strugg
you're struggling to understand
something because it's a point of
Des listen guys we're working on it
strategize trying to outlast because
facts common sense don't apply so think
desperation and that will get you there
H marri you know you know what I would
say to you to to me this is going to end
up making for the greatest movies you'll
ever watch in 10 years okay I'm telling
you right now years I I always say that
I'm like is there going to be a
documentary you think I think it's going
to be a movie or a doc and if it's a doc
it'll be like a 10 two season typ of
deal but because what could end up
happening history's going to you know
validate history will be kind to him no
you know Churchill said history will be
kind to me for I intend to write it
right so right he's writing it but the
part that you have to be also thinking
about is he's not campaigning right now
he's not out there but this may be by
far the biggest campaign donation help
in the world if you think about it one
time Joe when they were going after Joe
okay Rogan when he oh well comments he
made 15 years ago when he was four years
old or whatever you know Joe said this
and Joe said that and I made a video I
said do you guys realize I just I was
counting all the views on how much media
wrote I said do you know how much it
would cost you to get this kind of media
oppressed I said nearly $300 million
okay I said Joe ought to send a thank
you letter to everybody saying thank you
for spend giving me $300 million of free
coverage how much free coverage is Trump
getting what is the difference between
what they're doing today versus 2015
2016 when everybody wanted to have them
on and just trash them right CNN MSNBC
everybody was having them on and all of
a sudden like guys we we've been giving
him a lot of eyeballs yeah we got to
stop this knock it off what's going to
happen so anyway so that's happened here
too forget this year with Fox they
didn't have us on for a while that's
right and you guys are now doing the and
by the way uh uh uh are you still are
you still the senior advisor for trump
super pack Maga are you still an advisor
no I am actually now no I'm not involved
with Maga Inc I am actually the general
Council and spokeswoman for the save
America pack okay got it so you're the
GC you're the GC dealing with them legal
the GC yeah I thought I would just be
the GC and then all of a sudden I was
back on trial and I was like but you
know I love what I do and if he needs
there that's what I do great so so the
reason why I ask this question is this
so CNN is doing a uh a a republican
debate okay which somehow some way a guy
who you know is very eloquent Great
Communicator didn't make it didn't
qualify his name is Vic ramaswami and
the STIs made it and Haley made it and
Trump made it obviously Trump's not
going to be there because he's doing a
town hall same day with he doesn't need
to be he doesn't need to be he's going
to be doing that with Fox right so what
do you think about you know uh uh Vic
you know call calling out Rona ra
McDaniel and then now CNN is saying
you're not qualified to be on stage and
it's just going to be Haley and Des
santis how much games plays behind
closed doors that the average voter
doesn't know about a lot a lot I mean
they play games with me it's a lot um
you know they they feel like they're in
this position of power I always say
think of the media like you have a
Napoleon complex okay and they use their
little strength and CNN by the way has
very little strength right now but
they'll use their little strength and
they'll say I'm not putting you on and
that'll hurt you like it it's the same
thing as the lawsuits wake up you're not
hurting the you're helping the cuz now
he's going to have some little
microphone on Instagram or whatever and
he will get more attention because he's
been excluded yeah then just put the guy
on let them do what they want invite
them all you know but they're so
shortsighted honestly I don't understand
the thinking because it's so
small-minded and the numbers have shown
the more you try and exclude the more
you try and pound them down the more
their numbers go up it's just silliness
yeah why wouldn't you have there is
gamesmanship because you'll call them
out they don't like to be called out how
do you feel about Nikki Haley how do you
feel about
Nikki get me spicy I'm not a political
person so I'm going to start by saying
that I'm not on the campaign I'm not a
political person how do I feel about
Nikki Haley I think she's a
flip-flopper I don't trust her I uh I
wouldn't vote for her I I wouldn't now
what if on a crazy because there's you
know I don't of course you don't follow
the news and you don't follow what
people are saying at all because it's
not part of your job and you just kind
of like doing but there are certain
people speculating that there may be a
possibility that the Wall Street people
behind closed doors with these things
called packs that they raise a lot of
money packs like not pack 10 like
basketball P America pack yes like save
America type of packs that are saying
hey and and again rumors hey uh Mr
President Donald Trump J Trump if you
don't consider a Nikki Haley as your VP
we are not going to give you the money
that you know you need to go become the
president but if you choose Nikki Haley
we will consider you as a presidential
you know support money donors all that
stuff because the money went from the
santis to Haley so this is why president
Trump you should consider money Soros
gave her money a lot of people gave her
money a lot of people gave her money uh
all I would say to shut that down is
very simple president Trump will never
be in a position like that so you don't
think president he would never be strong
strong armed like that you think he
would consider a he doesn't need to he
would consider who he wants and who he
thinks would be a best fit I I know that
for a fact I mean he is not going to be
one of those it's true he's just not do
you think Haley would be a best fit now
you're now you're really there's no it's
just a couple cameras it's just like we
got 17
people we just said 20 20 people are
watching us right nowwhere they're all
from Minnesota cold weather nobody's
yeah I don't get ratings ever so it's
not you know this will go nowhere this
will be probably your worst watch show
sorry not sure why you had me on they uh
do I think nck look here's what I
think I don't I'm not I'm not um the
biggest fan I used to like Nikki Haley
when she was in the white house but
after she's just flip-flopping and I go
back to what I always say with Trump
loyalty and I just don't see that there
and I think that that's concerning for
me is she going to come in and be a
puppet is she if is she going to take
funding from people that I've already
seen that happen just to try and win you
know she's I also just don't think in a
debate she's incredibly I mean I could
debate I I really believe like if if I
was completely into politics and knew
everything about politics that I could
get up and debate her and have no
problem that's concerning for me I don't
want another Camala Harris right but if
the president believes that she would be
a good fit eventually MH God bless and
I'll get behind her but right now no I
don't see the the Nicki thing happening
at all okay what do you mean but listen
uh being blunt it's no secret that Trump
likes attractive capable women right
okay whether it's uh Ivanka Trump
whether it's Mara Maples whether it's
Melania whether it's um whoever he has
in his Corner whatever is going on you
so there's an attractive woman out there
that's been campaigning with him now I
know you don't like giving opinions but
her name is Christy oh Christy No
Christy no I think she's capable I think
she's gorgeous I think she's smart yeah
she was in Iowa yesterday she was just
campaigning with Trump she's my pick I
love her for most likely VP picks Vinnie
thinks that it's Sarah hucke Sanders I
said not so much in the face my op
because but but hold on but she's a
loyal but let's be real she was taking
fire in those all those white meetings
she was a
gangster also pretty loyal but you know
where is he yeah but the fly in his head
my point is this in your
not in your non opinionated way what are
the chances he considers someone like
idea I mean she's OB you met her before
you're not getting me in trouble you
think I'm stupid I don't know who he's
going to pick you ask my opinion she
seems lovely I don't really know I
haven't I've never even met her oh no um
maybe we've been at the same events but
no I really don't know her you know at a
while was Carrie Lake and it was it's
always somebody at the end of the day I
I can honestly say he does I don't think
he's Chosen and I I don't know that you
know when he does that I he I don't
think he has I don't think he F how
about this how about this it is way too
early would you say there's a better
chance this is off the Record no one's
watching that he picks a woman versus a
man better I think it matters to
it has to matter it's it has to matter
it does it well he picked I think it
Adam he picked pens he picked pens
unless if you you know identify Mr Pence
as a times have changed pbd this 2015
anymore it's probably going to be guys
Chris Christine yeah I think so too but
now that's pants big pants not but alen
boom Alina drops the
hands she told everyone
who1 com and I get sued for that that
was just a joke but how like let's say
hopefully he you know he wins and he
beats all this nonsense that they're
doing he's he's always warned about the
swamp he's always told you know drain
the swamp he's got he's going to come
back in and deal with all these
creatures how how can he trust no I know
I feel you how can you even cuz he's
going right back in how do you trust any
of these even the people that are like
Hey we're we're with you he knows who's
he knows oh that's list when he first
went in what happens is they right they
and this is my understanding right they
you go in okay it's like me going in to
say I'm a professional golfer I don't
know what I'm doing I'm calling I'm
calling my friend Sergio Garcia surge
help me tell me what club to buy he what
please tiger I don't think I'd call
Tiger I'll call Dustin Johnson I'll call
Bryson to Shambo I'll call I'll call my
people I'll be like tell me what to
do and you take their advice and you do
it and that's what happened the first
time around now now very different oh
yes I've gone through this I've weeded
out the bill bars I've weeded out the
people that are no good the people that
were actually working on the other
agenda but got to stay and they pushed
them the network he knows the network
which is why I love him going back so
much now because he knows the network in
he's seen the network against him and
now he's gets to go back and fix in a
major way with people that he trusts and
there will be people that screw him of
course it's like me saying that I've
never hired an associate that's
disappointing it happens but it will be
so much stronger it will be so much
stronger because I get these arguments
all the time Elina sorry Adam I get
these arguments because I have you know
cousins that are 100% like nothing the
country is Biden's just doing it's
infrastructure it's just you know
they're all they're all they're all
delusional but uh because they I have
these arguments they're like cuz I'm
talking about January 6 and how
Christopher Ray these people had FBI
there you know they say well Trump
appointed them I'm like who do you
thinko them that's not how it works and
the truth is I think that it's how it
will work I think he will clean up I
think you got to clean up from the top
down I've said that I can tell you that
um I think it's incredibly critical that
he puts the right people especially in
the doj um you know I I would you know
press secretary is just a the face of
and somebody who's communicating with
the Press but to me where I would want
to see the change is in the back in the
back the Press secret the the doj the
people that are enforcing laws the
people are that are actually going
counterterrorism things that are really
important to us uh cartels making sure
there's no uh you know epidemic no no
fentol uses our children are suffering
um depression things like that we got to
work inside out right and then and first
of all people are afraid of trump and
countries are afraid of trump and right
now they're not afraid of Biden so that
what puts me in my most fearful state is
we could go to war because we have such
weak leadership when you hear someone
like V say which I kind of I've been
watching a lot of it I'm kind of
agreeing when he's saying something like
the FBI can easily be just dismantled
and put and take all those agents and
put them in other organizations could we
could we operate as a country without an
FBI if you without an FBI without an FBI
I don't know enough about it to say so I
think that there's an importance to
National Security when it's done right
um I think fractured National Security
sometimes concerns me because I think if
there's no strong leadership in anything
in any in any company you have to think
of it like a company you have um you
know different sections then you have
high potential for weakness you have
high potential for somebody to permeate
you know having a manager of a store in
California and a manager store in
Florida but they're not interacting and
there's no oversight that concerns me
they got to report up got so I don't
necessarily agree with that structure as
somebody who's run a business in was 28
years old I I've seen that that doesn't
work I tried to open you know if you
don't have the the heads watching it can
go Ary yeah it's just it's just hard
though when it comes to the FBI cuz
going all the way back from the FBI's
beginning to like coming all these guys
their political bias affects what's
happening with the presidency with
Russia collusion with Hillary it's like
a contamination it's so but and it's so
hard because you don't know who if think
about it we're all in the FBI and Pat's
in charge and Pat hates Trump I don't
care what you're going to say there's
going to be investigations there's going
to be stuff happening because of his
bias and we saw it so it's it's kind of
hard I think I think uh Vinnie actually
posed a really good question about
draining the swamp and even you're like
before you even answered it you were
like yeah you kind of got a little Mr
Burns moment right there but I actually
think you're right about your answer
about why this time will be different
and I'll unpack it a little bit I think
it's a double-edged sword so the
advantage and the disadvantage of trump
being a business this man who's never
been in politics right he don't know
what he's walking into he could say it
all he wants he could say that he's
donated to every single campaign and
every single politician out there that
doesn't mean you're in the house you're
outside the house making donations you
don't really know how it works okay but
the difference is like an establishment
politician that's also a Double's edge
sword because you know how it works
you're going to play the game I scratch
my back scratch yours funny about my
back yada but this time around he's been
the politician he's he's been on the
outside he's been on the inside now he
knows how it works the inner workings he
knows the plumbing but he's also not
bought and paid for like a lot of these
politicians so I do think that this time
around it will be different but it goes
to show that if you don't know how
Washington works I'm sorry you're going
to get run over you're going to get run
a mock you think you're going to have
people around you that are that are
helping you they're all social climbers
or political social climbers there's a
lot of people he brought in his Circle
that did not have his best interest no
so many of them were there already
though remember that they were there
already and they were told this is the
guy you want he was advised he was
leaning on a lot of people to advise him
when he went and I've spoken to him
about this and and just you know
wondered and he's look it's going to be
different because I now know so so let
me ask you is is the is the president a
trump a forgiving man once you're like
for example let's just say you you were
disloyal okay now your back being loyal
is he forgiving that quickly
and he thinks he can change people's
minds and be back with him and the
reason why I ask this question is the
following reason I ask it
because this time around see you know
like the famous line because you'd be in
jail yeah but she didn't go to jail
nothing happened to her and you just
said something earlier today how is it
that the list Epstein list came out he
should be in jail why is he not in jail
so what's what's what's he going to do
that a lot of you know the V voters who
are saying okay if you're if you're
going to say you're going to clean up
the doj is going to clean up FBI is
going what does that mean Ray's going to
get fired okay ray is not it's a deeper
issue than that right what what else is
going to happen on second term if you're
back in the office is it you know that's
probably the biggest like some of the
people that voted for him that maybe are
thinking to come back or sit it out like
I just don't think anything's going to
change right I just I just don't trust
the system cuz I don't think he's going
to do anything what do you think's going
to happen with him being in the office
this time and how quickly you think he's
going to hold those people accountable
like fouchy hasn't been held accountable
I think very quickly I think number one
knowing him look I don't know I'm I'm I
don't speak to him about this this is
not my world but I know him I think that
if he makes a promise he'll keep it
meaning um you know he needs to do a lot
of work he he says he's like if we don't
get this back quickly you know I have to
get back quickly to clean up number one
you have to pick up the phone and call
foreign leaders you can't be afraid he I
don't think that's been happening you
got to pick up the phone just like he
used to just like he did with Putin and
people says he says Putin's smart he
says this person well they're not stupid
he's not saying they're smart we should
praise them he's saying you need to not
underestimate them and I think that
that's been going on we're just closing
our eyes and ignoring it and letting
them permeate every part of this country
so I think he will take a really strong
stance number one want to secure us to
make sure we don't go to war number one
and I I know he that I believe 100% yeah
um in terms of because it happened in
the four years we didn't have any issues
Isis disappeared a lot of things if
Trump was president today Ukraine Russia
what is this we had no Wars we had
brought our boys home and now we've got
you know we're leaving from day one
leaving what was it 80 billion dollar of
equipment and leaving our people in the
airports chasing planes Afghanistan what
the hell is going on we knew they didn't
know what they were doing it it was like
they were assisting from day one here
take our equipment take our stuff why
don't we make you stronger terrorists
you are amazing goggles and our amazing
equipment with the high what are we
doing he will do what he says he will
back be back to Old Trump he is Trump he
will do what he needs to do and that's
not vindictive it's not uh uh somebody
coming after people who can't it's not
that it's we're losing America I truly
believe that we are losing America and
it's going to be too late if he doesn't
get in honestly don't think even a
little bit a little bit cuz even said on
day one on day one I know I'll I'll be
retribution only take me one day it only
take me one day we listen we know Trump
okay we could say all the best things
about Trump we could we could we could
say how bad we need a strong leader in
power right but you know there's a
little part of trump that wants to get
some people back that wants to seek
retribution there's a little bit of that
would you at least admit that absolutely
not you don't think Trump she's not okay
at least that what's your question no
I'm saying that Trump he even said on
day one he's going to seek retribution
you know there's a little part
of is a little like all right you
with me I'm going to with you back
I don't think there's anything wrong
with
thatn 1,000% for the past it'll be eight
years from the moment he said it they
have been trying to destroy his life and
you know for what because this guy loves
America say what the hell you want he
pulled open a curtain and said hey
America look at these that's
what he did and he's been suffering 100%
he deserves to do whatever the hell he's
going to do in the legal hold holding
people accountable isn't like a I was
just going to say that let's just look
if I was his lawyer standing next to him
that day that he said it I would have
said let's instead say we're going to
hold everyone accountable accountable
and and that's the real truth is there
should be no reason that somebody gets
raided for library books mhm and
somebody else doesn't there should be no
reason that a pedophile is exposed and
doesn't go to jail okay but then he is
Accused by somebody who wants to write
books and do or whatever of terrible
things that are so disgusting that he
did not do so we're going to look at the
world and say that's retribution that's
not retribution that's called Equal
justice that's called due process they
will go through due process if they
didn't do anything wrong prove it but we
can't keep saying that it's normal that
Hunter Biden tried to sneak through with
absolute immunity with an agreement that
got caught by a judge imagine if that
judge was a little tired that day and
just you know or on the take or whatever
and let it go thank God for people that
are awake but that's what he's talking
about we need to clean up we need the
country to believe in the country again
we need the country to believe in the
justice system again so yes there will
be accountability that's what attorney
generals do that's what Departments of
Justice do um they don't Target people
they hold people
accountable and that's the fear Alena is
the word cuz Pat had everybody pick a
word for this year all right mine was
undeniable I'm going to be undeniable
this year Trump's thing is like you said
that accountability that is pumping fear
in all these people CU they're like oh
my God he's going to hold our feet to
the fire that's the fear by the way
that's what's making want to put him in
jail SC exactly that's exactly Alina you
brought up something you said if I was
Trump's lawyer and I was sitting next to
him that day well you know news flash
you are his lawyer I'm not that I'm not
a campaign lawyer I'm not involved in
that you know I would he did say you
know how often you probably can't answer
this but you know Leticia James this
stupid b you know whatever he said You
Know Jack by way I say that too so okay
Jack Smith is corrupt you know the woke
left like yeah but that's as an attorney
yeah how how do you say to the president
yes just don't say certain things that
might affect your case
how do you approach that CU he's Trump
GNA Trump you see Trump GNA Trump how is
an attorney I'm sure there's some things
that get frustrated other attorneys have
said this where it's like don't talk
about that for now how do you deal with
something like that I mean I'm not going
to break privilege um I can tell you
that any client that I deal with has a
right to speak their mind it's called
the first amendment when you're the
leading political candidate of a country
that's falling apart I I think you're
angry I think that comes out however way
he wants it gets him the attention
that's making him lead in the polls I
think Americans feel angry and when they
see his anger it's what makes him
relatable so I'm not here to advise him
on how to be a strategist I'm not here
to advise him on his campaign I'm here
to be his lawyer so as his lawyer what
would I do I would say don't use words
that could get you sued don't you know
be careful
um that's what I would say to any client
if you're in a public eye I mean there's
just it's it's the reality of the world
we're in right it's anybody defamation
is really what we're talking about so
that's the only thing that I worry about
is defamation gag orders unfortunately
have become part of what I have to deal
with I was gagged I never even said
anything but I was gagged because they
didn't want me to say something and I
couldn't even say something in the court
on the record I'm still gagged uh in the
AG case Vinnie not that kind of gagged
bro relax I know I know what gag order
gag
order um but yeah I mean you can't you
can't and I wouldn't my advice to him is
as any lawyer would be be careful of
certain words um you know choose them
wisely but it's president Trump I mean I
have I have respect for the man he led
the Free World I mean who am I to tell
him what not to yeah I'm his lawyer I'll
advise him but he's he's got a ton of
people around him and at the end of the
day it's him it's his brand it's who he
is let's go to the last topic here
before we wrap up uh yes which is the
Jeffrey Epstein list that came out last
night you know middle of the night
Twitter's Going Bonkers videos you're
seeing some videos are extremely you
know uh uh stepen Hawkin I don't know if
you saw some of the cartoons all the
cartoons were horrible and apparently he
was in what uh underage orgies like I
can't even picture St em saying to hide
it and he would would pay anybody so
good for me it's not funny but Sten yeah
Steven Hawkin oh and they said uh Alan
dtz Pat I guess uh Epstein forced
underage girls to have sex with Allan
what does that mean though Force like go
go have like making them have sex with
the guy allegedly that's in the cour
let's just use the word allegedly first
of all there's 91 charges in Trump's
court case that doesn't mean he did that
you know it's it's it's
I I never ever would you know Allan I
have a lot of respect for I think he's
incredibly smart person um there are
literally groups coming after attorneys
that speak their mind and he's liberal
and I I just respect intelligence I
don't respect pedophilia so 1,000% and
it's period the end there's nothing left
for me to say on that if you're a
pedophile you better 100% you see these
names Trump's on this list Clinton's on
this list dwoods but the one name theist
no no meaning like was in his orbit was
on his playing he never no he never flew
never went to the no never went to the
never talked under never he never met
with Epstein no met with him pictures of
him party or whatever not met with him
that's all I'm talking about guys they
met together but the one name but wait a
minute wait a minute he was not friend
there's a there's a there's a difference
there's a difference between 50 flights
to the island and you're in New York
City with your son you're okay so you
know we had Mike Tyson here one time and
Mike Tyson I think was the last time we
had him on he he says one day he says
I'm doing what I'm doing and all of a
sudden it was who came to him Vice or
SWAT or FBI came to him oh cuz the guy
that did something crazy right how do
you know this man he says what do you
mean how do I know this man he says well
you took a picture with him you know
what he just did he just killed 28
people or whatever it was like he
stabbed and killed the he say dude a
guy's taking a picture with me I'm not
going to know what it is so think about
how many parties you've been been to
okay some of those parties you went to
maybe one or two no but how many people
were at the party there's a difference
between you going to those parties
versus hey Adam come to the island that
I have here with 27
times let me put a portrait of you in a
blue dress with heels in the front of
that's a different conversation
so lot of I stand correct I'm not saying
and I'm just but what I'm getting at
you're absolutely right zero contention
the name that is the most liable here is
the royal family prince Andrew you've
seen what's going on with this guy I
don't know if is that the actual
painting that is the painting beyond
weird you know what's we what's telling
is where he put it where he put that
painting that painting was in the
entrance so when you came in right the
entrance of his apartment New York I
believe that painting was in the
entrance why that's a power play that
tells you I own you wow big so gangster
who that was in Clinton's that was
apartment when you walk into I
think it I mean we can fact check me but
when you walk into the right it's there
you put a former president in a dress in
high heels in your entry of your
apartment what does that say my own wait
is that supposed to be the Lewinsky
dress by the way I don't know that's a
great question it might be but the
prince Andrew thing yeah I mean as a as
a how do you defend that as a lawyer you
don't I mean he I wouldn't take
that case why not because it's the to me
unless he could show me that this was
not the I would have a I have a very
hard time with pedophilia look just
because I'm a lawyer I represented a a
child who was a victim of rape by a man
who raped 20-some other children in a
state by a state employee he was a
systemic rapist he would groom these
children usually divorced children and
he was the only one not within the
statute of limitations that could bring
a lawsuit so I couldn't do a class
action I did this I got you know we we
resolved the case he's fine he had drug
addiction all these things from that I
can't as a human being I can't defend
that I can't and and some lawyers maybe
they can maybe how do lawyers defend
something like that I always ask
criminal lawyers because sometimes
you're mitigating damages you're not
trying to uh prove prove them innocent
you're just trying to mitigate and
negotiate and by the way I'd probably be
a great criminal attorney I'm not a
criminal attorney um I I you know I
would have a very difficult time as a
human being as a mother with uh
representing somebody who I believed was
a ped Al so and from a loyal a lawyer
standpoint uh the list came out New
Mexico Governor Bill Richardson
billionaire HUD hedge fund manager Glenn
Dubin the prince the list goes on and on
Clinton there was certain names
especially one that was just heavily
redacted yeah okay this is my question
there's obviously I don't know no no
victims God I feel so bad for them I
I'll pray for them but how are they
still protecting a name of a person that
well they're not protecting the name how
they why they why they why they
so legally what happens so no there has
to be motions filed to unseal and people
can try and do that and I'm sure some of
these you know the uh the Tom Fitts of
the world Etc will'll try and do so um
there there's so people always say you
know it's not all public and I want the
world to understand this when I when I
have a case when I'm doing a lawsuit
like there are things you just don't
know that are not public sometimes the
court orders them be private there are
private conversations with judges and
all the all the parties and there ccil
that are sealed um for certain reasons
for protection reasons um there are I
don't understand why that is unsealed I
don't like it and I would love to know
as an attorney um I think that no matter
what if this goes to trial we will know
because they can't um have and I'd be
shocked if the Press doesn't make a
motion to have it filmed and and public
but there will be transcripts and all of
that at this point you don't know
there's so many identity issues and when
you're you're dealing with uh minors and
rape victims there's a lot of of issues
that happen sometimes it's to protect
the rape uh victim that they don't want
their name being associated with that
blackout name because they're afraid of
being killed and then they have to be in
there's so many things that go on that
people don't realize now what do I think
in here no I'm not going to think that I
think that that's somebody who's very
high-profile obviously there's
speculation as to who it could be um
somebody uh but I can't understand how
Bill Clinton would be revealed but this
person wouldn't yeah like who who more
like this is the ex president of the
United States his name is all over but
this one heavily redacted name you know
who I know it's not Donald Trump Donald
J Trump but the left must be going crazy
CU they just proved all the stuff that
we talking about who who is protect them
more than him though I was just going to
say would it be a Bill Gates maybe a
Spielberg this person is Tom Hanks how
do we know it's one person that's
heavily one of them it's one name it's
one name that I kept seeing that was
just redacted I think that's strange
isn't that weird unless they're
cooperating you know there's so many
elements that we don't know that's why
we have the attorney yeah they could be
a cooperating witness I'm not sure I'm
not sure what that would be it's so it's
so interesting because I you have to
remember so much happens before the
public knows um you have you know I've
been in front of a grand jury you know
and people didn't know and they pull you
in they see if you're going to be part
of the papers that's all stuff that they
do and then they pick and choose and
they put their storyline together and
they decide which Witnesses they're
going to rely on but there's a ton of
people that go in front of a grand jury
and testify and then what they do is and
it's really unfair because a grand jury
um is one-sided you're not allowed to
have your lawyer in there you go by
yourself and it's it's a frightening
experience for anybody and you just have
government the FBI the doj in there you
have you know the grand jurors and they
can ask you whatever you want you're not
represented in there um you can leave
and ask a question to your Lord but you
are by yourself and you you know if you
have nothing to hide you have nothing to
hide I had nothing to hide I went in I I
was honest but if you have something to
hide I could imagine uh that then opens
the door to witness witnesses that flip
witnesses that cooperate they plea so
there are so many things that could have
happened there um that people don't
realize before it becomes public but I'm
happy that it's becoming public this is
you me both and I saw something where
it's like the I don't know if the
government or the FBI want of them have
all these boxes of all the recordings
and everything that he actually was
recording all these people on the island
all the cameras all the hidden cameras
about he had a room like this Pat with
all these TVs and recording everything
so when they would leave Alina and he'd
ask hey I need this favor and the
person's like no he's like oh really
that's you with this underage girl or
whatever and they would do all to me
that is the most believable proposition
right there 100% there's anything we
know about Epstein is he's recording all
you mother and that's why he was so
powerful and was hundreds of millions
of that's why allegedly he might not be
he himself yeah that's right his
business model was blackmail 100% okay
all the child weird stuff pedophilia
dude that's all a means to an end he is
using whatever he can to get dirt on
powerful people left right center up
down he got and who was he working for
is the real question I'm surprised
gain's still there that's crazy I'm
surprised they she hasn't she hasn't
wanted to off herself yeah that's kind
of odd that she still you know you know
what this does tell you though I mean
you're looking at the stuff okay did you
ever meet anybody famous when you were
with Jeffrey she asked uh I met Michael
Jackson at Epstein's house in Palm Beach
asked whether she massaged Jackson she
said I did not ask for
Copperfield uh uh she said that he
attended dinner at one of Epstein's home
and did some magic tricks Did You
observe David Copperfield to be a friend
of Jeffrey Epstein she asked she replied
in the affirmative did Copperfield ever
discuss Epstein involvement with young
girls with you she was also asked he
questioned me if I was aware that girls
were getting paid to find other girls
Copperfield she said in a deposition
didn't tell her any specifics of the
question did he say whether they were
teenagers or anything along those lines
she also ask he did not Trump those
Association repor mention documents so
Jeffrey great well call up Trump and
we'll go I don't recall the name of the
casino but we'll go to the casino and
then ask at one point whether she ever
gave a massage to Trump no the and this
is going right okay so here's the thing
when you're reading
this there's two things here
one you know you have to know these guys
are sitting around talking to their
lawyers talking to their people like
what are we going to do and then they're
calling each other like hey man what's
your plan what I saw you there dog you
what are you up to who's your lawyer
what do we want to do with this did you
call that guy did you call this guy you
know cuz they know who's name is blacked
out of course if there's anybody that
knows the people that have been there
know like they you know not no because
no not necessarily I'm going to correct
you because I have been like I said I'll
use my experience okay I'm not going to
speculate but in my experience I have
been in a front of a grand jury and I
shocking it's like what they do to every
Trump lawyer right they they like scare
you they bring you in things that I had
nothing to do with and they you know I
had no idea who went in I still don't I
don't know everybody that went in I
don't know I don't know who went in
because we all have different lawyers
and who went into the grand who went
into grand juries I don't know no no I'm
saying people that went to the house
yeah but they all don't know who was
involved in that and who the other guy
might be because once you go into a
grand jury right that's not that's not
that's not testimony that you get until
you're on the what I'm saying is like if
you go if you go to a party right and
you
know we're in Vegas okay bud of M my
dad's like where you going I I'll be
back I'm 14 15 years old the story my
dad told the other day right in Aspen so
I go downstairs my friends you know
we're all trouble teenagers at the time
we don't have any direction in life
we're in this Cadillac we take the dad's
car he's driving my friend 15-year old
guy he's driving I'm 15 not legal to
drive no not yet but but it's like 2:00
in the morning guy pulls up on this side
okay and Five Guys from New York where
you from New York where you from
Burbank okay boom guns come out then all
of a sudden oh my God here we go so we
run out run run run run run run
everybody craziness and then go back to
the room my dad's like why are you
breathing so hard I was just
exercising 2:00 in the morning what are
you going to do I'm just going to sleep
so what happened he doesn't find out
till I'm 32 years old when I tell him
this I'm like d you don't need to but
but the people who were in the Cadillac
know right the people who were in the
Cadillac no so the concern here becomes
the following here two two stories here
one the these money powerful people that
have been able to control their their
card to get away with stuff like
this they did not think today was coming
they did not think that this thing was
going to be public you think they were
thinking was no they're like I don't
know if this day is going to be coming
they probably thought he was doing
everything to protect them he was doing
everything to protect them so January
21st apparently the list all the other
names between now and then is going to
be released moral the story folks this
is more having nothing to do with
politics having to do with you man be
very careful what parties you go to okay
and you accept invitations to okay do a
lot of due diligence before you say yes
to any party you're going to be going to
and if you're going to be going ask very
specific questions are any of the guest
pedophile yeah is I would like a roster
is there a pedophile lit pedophile is
the party on an island party on an
island are there miners massaging people
and FYI between then and now think how
much social
media if social media was around like
you had smartphones back then people
didn't go on that thing on smartphones
think about like wow people would be on
the island yo what up here on Jeffrey
eps's Island we out here oh my God put
the phone down guy what are you doing oh
no they would do what they do at comedy
shows like Dave Chappelle when you walk
into the comedy club Alena there's a bag
you put your phone in they lock it till
you leave so you don't record the
performance yeah oh my God I mean look
demons listen but you can only control
so much I agree I totally agree TR
listen trust me you don't think I've
taken a picture with some weirdo that I
don't know about comes up to me and says
can I take your picture you know that by
the way that that by the way that's what
happened to Trump he's got a picture
with somebody and she's like oh he
attacked me he raped me he this that and
the other me he's like I don't remember
taking this picture I don't I don't know
who you are and he B and then he gets
defamation R the bigger you are the more
popular you are the more notoriety you
have the more pictures they're going to
ask you for I know and and didn't didn't
Trump ban Epstein from marago right
that's right I wasn't going to bring it
up but I'm glad you did TR Trump
actually threw him out of the club yeah
out of the club because he flirted with
someone's daughter younger daughters
like no we're not we don't do that here
yeah you out you're out yeah right there
Trump banned Jeffrey EP from marago sex
criminal on member's Daughter by the way
that was back in the day that just tells
you who he is he's not he's not into
creepy he he's just not he's you know it
was a long time ago it before any of
this but he was a member and Epstein was
a wealthy Palm Beach guy who threw
parties and then the people that figured
out who he was probably bowed out or
threw them out of his club like
President Trump um and then the other
ones that were into it I'm sure what has
Trump said about Epstein on the record
meaning like he's so happy he threw him
out of the club and never went to the is
yeah did he say he thought he was like a
scumbag pile did he well I I'm sure I
mean I'm not going to talk about what he
I don't know publicly I'm saying
publicly he's I think he's you know
you're not he's not concerned I never
went to the island I'm not a pedophile
and I threw him out of my club I mean
what better facts do you need them and
by just off of person and we talked
about this the last podcast I just look
at what Bill Gates's wife Melinda Gates
said when she goes I met him one time I
had nightmares and it was evil
personified that's a freaking crazy
statement to be like I just met him and
I felt like theil think he's your for
being a I mean how about her gain like a
grooming oh she's yeah she's she's a
love what what happens to galain at this
point from an attorney honestly from an
attorney's perspective as a as a as a
conspiracy person I just hope because I
would like her to testify I would like
to see this one I would like to see this
one look how rough she looks right now
you have evil inside you look at that
how can she not testify I mean only if
she how does that work only if she dies
right so they're going to bring her on
TR Tri I mean they already have they
have to bring her on I mean she you know
she's got to be she's got to testify and
I hope it doesn't get sealed only the
identities of the vi identities of the
victims should be sealed but as far as
the Predators those should not be sealed
and they should be bringing charges
against those people and I think frankly
now that it's public there's going to be
a tremendous amount of pressure to see
them do the right thing and go after
people that are now we have the facts
I'm a little disappointed that it takes
media to get us there can I be honest
with you like why did we need to see it
for you to have to bring charges because
as of today there are no charges brought
right against Bill Clinton for sleeping
with underage uh individuals those
victims are alive where what's happening
prince prince andless of his of his
friends I don't give a dam why why
haven't they this is actually a good
question why your Ro tell us why haven't
they why has why hasn't some lawy you're
gone to the L to to the girl can't be
the lawyer has to be the government
government has this case the government
government needs to bring oh civil suit
sure a civil suit on behalf of the women
but they were settled yeah Chase gave
them 29 Million by Bank yeah a bank a
bank settled the suit paid for it can
jpan JP Morgan which I believe was $290
million because guess what their top
brass were involved in all these emails
going over there doing their dirt with
them Patrick a settlement follow the
moneyy and part of the settlement is you
will no longer sue us you will take this
check you will shut up will go away it's
a settlement agreement settlement
Agreements are fair you're allowed to
have settlement agreements you're
allowed to say I don't want to litigate
as a victim I can imagine not wanting to
go through litigation not wanting to be
this publicly display your rape and your
trauma again that's incredibly traumatic
you know they suffer from PTSD real
things real victims let me be clear um
because we have this other legal issue
happening in our country right now with
with the adult survivors act and some of
these claims that are coming very late
that are um some of them are fake some
of them are real but the ones that are
fake it bothers the hell out of it um so
you know we'll see but I will tell you
outside of the settlement agreement for
cash there needs to be criminal and
that's the state the government needs to
bring charges to people that they know
raped underage women 100% think end you
think if Trump gets elected that that'll
happen I can tell you if I'm involved in
the doj please please do it I that is
something that I I I have no tolerance
for that none I would and it's crazy
good elen and guess what the majority of
these people that should be your number
one priority people Safety Rap children
kids kids that's that's the Border
problem we have rape after rape I mean
oh they go disappear the little kid you
know they have the underwear of these
children it's like a trophy have you
seen these videos at the border if you
look if you if you do some research I
mean doesn't take much there are
individuals that have gone down there
and and exposed how much what they do is
they rapee the children and then they
hang the underwear on the uh fence to
show that they've raped children and
it's all kids underwear and it's so
disturbing the most disturbing
disturbing what's the what's the it's
just gangs and sickos I mean I look
understand that a lot of these people
that are coming over that are fleeing in
a way that can't get in through a legal
manner are because they can't get in
through the legal means that this
country allows for we allow migrants we
allow immigrants we we are pro
immigration what we are not is for
people who have been charged who are
criminals who can't get into our country
securely so that we know who's coming in
so that we can allow you in the right
way and you get vetted and and you're
not a terrorist and go through the
normal means we can't have those people
so what are they doing they're Crossing
illegally we've heard that there's you
know Chinese migrants going through
Middle East everybody everybody mother
everybody look terrorists and it's just
an open entry way so they're raping and
these are probably people that were
rapists we don't know who's coming in
because they're just coming said about
this has been a great podcast appreciate
you for coming out uh keep doing what
you're doing keep staying tough and
looking forward to seeing what happens
and what can people find you by the way
is it is it just so not Alina hob I'm
Alina hob on Twitter on Truth social
which I I'm more active on and of course
Instagram fantastic there you go rob
let's put the link below for everything
Alina I would say uh in ass Syrian thank
you for coming out it wouldn't mean
anything okay all right we'll take that
we we'll do that but uh looking forward
to hope hopefully doing this again
sometime in the future thank you by the
way if I don't say this my brother is
your biggest fan and he told me I swear
to God if you go on what's what's his
name his name is fuad
fad fuad much love to you next time come
visit we'd love to meet you take care
everybody bye bye bye- bye bye- bye
thank
you